MIGUEL HERNAN: Cigarette smoking is
one of the most important global health
problems.
The World Health Organization
estimates that tobacco
kills about 6 million people each year.
Cigarette smoking has a
causal effect on many cancers
and heart disease, stroke,
respiratory diseases, you name it.
But everybody knows this, right?
And yet for decades cigarette ads
showed tough, healthy men smoking.
But reality is something
hard to argue against.
At least four Marlboro men died
of smoking related diseases.
And some well-known Hollywood
actors also advertised cigarettes.
One died of cancer,
the other of dementia,
which begs the question: does
smoking have a causal effect
on the risk of dementia.
There are biological
reasons why smoking may
increase the risk of at
least some forms of dementia.
However, we will never have a
randomized trial of cigarette smoking.
Fortunately, such unethical
trial is not allowed.
That means that we'll have to
rely on observational data only.
In fact, several observational
prospective studies
of smoking and dementia have
been conducted since the 1990s.
However, the findings of
these observational studies
vary dramatically.
Some studies found a higher risk of
dementia in smokers than in nonsmokers.
Other studies found the opposite.
Can we interpret any of these
associations as the effect of smoking
on dementia?
And if so, what's the answer?
Does smoking cause or prevent dementia?
And most importantly, why do
results differ across studies?
One possibility is
uncontrolled confounding
in some of the studies,
for example, by alcohol.
People who become cigarette smokers
also tend to drink more alcohol.
If alcohol increases
the risk of dementia,
then we would expect to find
an association between smoking
and dementia, even if smoking
had no effect on dementia.
But it looks like many observational
studies of smoking and dementia
did adjust for the most
important confounders.
Then why did the smokers have a higher
risk of dementia in some studies
and a lower risk of
dementia in other studies?
Let me give you a hint.
Perhaps it has to do with
the selection of individuals
in each of these studies.
We will return to this problem
at the end of this lesson.
And by then you will be able to
explain what's going on here.